les pour joe biden le marathon européen
continue le président américain est
arrivé en pologne il y à quelques
minutes maintenant dans la ville de
rzeszow située à environ 80 km de la
frontière avec l'ukraine il doit
s'entretenir avec son homologue polonais
angel duda on va retrouver tout de suite
notre envoyé spécial pauline godard
bonjour pauline vous êtes donc à rzeszow
un cette ville où doit arriver joe biden
tout à l'heure
oui c'est une ville vous le disais qu'il
n'a pas été choisie au hasard
puisqu'elle se trouve à 80 kilomètres de
la frontière ukrainienne l accueil de
nombre et de nombreux réfugiés ukrainien
mais aussi une de bases militaires ont
été déployés depuis déjà quelques
semaines plusieurs milliers de soldats
américains qui sont venus renforcer les
rangs de l'otan joe biden devrait
normalement d'ailleurs s'y rendre
aujourd'hui le président america et en
pologne pour deux jours il a décidé un
de mettre à l'honneur la pologne puisque
le pays accueille je vous le rappelle
plus de la moitié des réfugiés ukrainien
soit près de deux millions de personnes
la pologne est aux portes du conflit
elle est inquiète elle se sent menacée
par moscou les deux pays alors affichent
leur unité en valent sans doute le voir
pendant cette visite qui n'était
pourtant pas encore le cas un pas le cas
il ya encore quelques temps puisque je
vous le rappelle le président polonais
est un soutien de l'ancien président
américain donald trump mais la guerre en
ukraine a rebattu les cartes et la
pologne et les états unis ont décidé
donc d'afficher cette unité joe biden
doit d'ailleurs rencontrer demain
longuement le président polonais et il
doit aujourd'hui faire un point sur
faire un état des lieux sur les besoins
de la pologne en aide humanitaire aide
humanitaire qu'ils doivent ou qu'ils
aimeraient à fournir d'autant plus aux
réfugiés ukrainien oui et rzeszow à 1
pauline là où vous vous trouvez doit
être comme beaucoup d'autres villes
polonaises submergé un peu par l'arrivée
de tous ces réfugiés ukrainien on
l'imaginé
oui en effet la gare de rzeszow il ya
également un centre qui est qui est en
place et puis juste derrière moi ce
souffre se trouve pardon un autre centre
d'accueil alors on n'a pas pu rentrer
sains et filmé dans ce centre mais on a
pu le visiter sans caméras actuellement
se trouve une centaine de réfugiés ce
centre pendant accueillir jusqu'à 500 on
a pu y voir de nombreux elle lit les
personnes ici peuvent se reposer
peuvent-ils dormir pendant deux jours
environ alors nous ont expliqué que au
bout de deux jours si jamais évidemment
ces réfugiés ne trouvait pas où aller au
cas par cas il pouvait rester encore
dans ce centre il y à des douches il y a
de quoi se vêtir de nombreux vêtements
car la plupart des réfugiés s'en vont
avec une toute petite veut lier valises
quand ils fuient l'ukraine on a vu
également une grande salle de jeux qui a
été aménagé pour les enfants et ça c'est
très important puisqu'on a vu des gens
des enfants retrouver un petit peu le
sourire et retrouver un peu d'innocence
après tout ce qu'ils ont vécu vous savez
depuis qu'on est ici on a pu le
constater c'est ça qui est qu'il n'est
vraiment pas évident c'est clair la
plupart des réfugiés que l'on voit que
ce soit à medica à la frontière ap chez
michel à la gare dans les centres qu'on
a pu visiter encore une fois ce sont
principalement des femmes et des enfants
et des personnes âgées qui sont là et à
qui ces bénévoles tentent tant bien que
mal de d'apporter un petit peu de
réconfort est d'ailleurs une bénévole à
qui nous avons pu parler nous a expliqué
les larmes aux yeux et bien qu'elle
pleurait qu'elle pleurait tous les jours
seules chez elles ou bien avec des
réfugiés elle nous a dit c'est injuste
ils n'ont rien demandé ce n'est pas
juste ce qui est en train de se passer
merci beaucoup pauline godard en direct
de rzeszow où doit se rendre tout à
l'heure joe biden le président américain
merci à vous